can I show you my fancy bag of clothes
yes I think I've got some good stuff for
us all Nokia's I want to celebrate the
finish right I got some classics here
come in here wow these are we got a few
of these and then I thought you might
like this one this is like maybe if you
could me style okay yeah yeah do you
want to go sorta you know almost
underarm like that or this is just pure
overall I don't know I think I would go
over armed because I'm used to that one
yeah I'm looking forward to you
embarrassing me all right here goes
nothing
holy [ __ ] yeah Wow it is said not by me
but by their nordic neighbors the
finished people are weirdos Oh
their language is basically elvish
[Music]
they're aloof and do not engage with
strangers or conduct Smalltalk
their hobbies include competitions such
as wife Carrie air guitar playing and
obviously cellphone broke and yet here I
am on a cool Helsinki morning hanging
out with Finland's future Olympic
javelin thrower lasse had a lot alone
all right you pick all I had to do to
make this happen was slide right into
his DMS and promised to bring some old
Nokia's it turns out that the Finns are
in fact very hospitable and that their
cell phones are sturdy I think until
they are not
is there a metaphor in all this
something bigger being said about
Finland's nosedive into a technology
apocalypse and subsequent rise is a
vibrant inventive force in the
technology industry not sure but I'm
gonna go with yes and try to prove it to
you what comes next
[Music]
we all know the idea of a company town
but here in Finland something really
unusual happened it became more of a
company nation during the early to mid
2000s Finland's economy boomed driven
almost entirely by Nokia in its heyday
Nokia accounted for 40% of all mobile
phones sold and one out of every two
smartphones sold then the 2007 something
terrible happened to Finland Apple
released the iPhone I've come here to
Helsinki to find out what happened in
the aftermath of Nokia's decline and
what startups have risen to take its
place
for starters I'll need a primer on the
decline and fall of Nokia and as luck
would have it this long haired gentleman
david cord wrote a book by that very
title
he also happens to be an American but
nobody's perfect you know when I was
researching this episode were just
telling people what we were gonna do
especially some of the younger people
had already they're like you know was
Nokia that big of a deal
because I remember them being seeking
out the kings of the mobile industry
well Nokia was huge in Finland they were
integrated than everything in the
Finnish culture finns were very proud of
what nokia did it was our success it was
Finland's success nokia started way back
in 1865 as a paper products company
plush toilet paper was its first hit it
got into boots tires cables all kinds of
stuff and then began making cell phones
first for this cool guy in the 60s and
then for all of us can you hear me now
the new iPhone is cool and all life was
grand for Nokia and for Finland from
these glorious headquarters by the
Baltic Nokia poured money into the
Finnish social system and then this
raging capitalist named Steve Jobs came
along and ruined everything today Apple
is going to reinvent the phone and here
it is
hey the iPhone was crazy right because I
remember in this like ridiculously quick
period of time it's not like the company
was wiped off the face of the earth but
I mean it'll just lost the phone
industry when Nokia started to stumble I
started to fail many people took that
rate personally it was a Finnish failure
there were you know thousands of people
who are unemployed in the factory
workers
and software developers in its moment of
greatest desperation Nokia's phone
divisions suffered that greatest of
dishonours getting sold to Microsoft
yeah it was tough there's a town called
Nokia in Finland which actually the
company was named for and the day the
announcement broke a vandal went and
changed the the town sign to Microsoft
it before upset that you know we used to
be on the top of the world and now it's
all gone
Nokia of course still exists and makes
things namely telecommunications and
data infrastructure gear but where the
company used to employ thirty five
thousand people in Finland it now only
employs thirty five hundred gonna pour
what out for the nose
[Music]
after new kia everyone was always
talking about what's the next Nokia what
is the next big company that will be
able to go international and to have
such a big impact on Finland and many
people at the time thought maybe with
review
Rovio created Angry Birds one of the
first gaming mega hits of the iPhone age
but while they had a few hot years it
soon became clear that Nokia levels
success was not in the cards eventually
we came to the side that's not gonna
happen again we need to be more diverse
we need instead of having one gigantic
company we need to have a 10 good
profitable mid-sized companies the birds
may not have replaced the notes but they
did kick off a gaming boom in Finland
one that came to be dominated by
supercell the maker of all your favorite
games and the master of your time
[Music]
supercell has only 300 or so employees
but it raked in about 1.6 billion
dollars last year 100 million people
plays games every day some of them
spending thousands of dollars to upgrade
their compounds and farms and all of
this winning happens in a strictly shoes
off workplace a common trope among
finished startups that supercell claims
to have invented Bilka here the CEO is
beloved by his countrymen for creating
Finland's biggest post Nokia success
story I'm here to find out how he did it
and hopefully score some free upgrades
and clash of clans you know for my kids
when you guys started supercell what
were you trying to do maybe in the
gaming industry that was was different
you know it seems to us that most games
companies where Oregon organized very
like in a very traditional way basically
they had this hierarchy and the
underlying assumption is that the
leadership knows best what to do but in
in games business I feel that it
actually is the game developers who are
obviously are they're closest to the
games they know best I put double gains
the company should do so therefore we
had this idea that what if you would
look fleets this traditional model like
you know the game developers would own
the vision of what double kings they
would do the strategy has made super so
one of the most coveted places for game
developers to land a job like Seth here
the game engineer on clash Royale who
moved all the way from San Francisco I'd
always been aware of supercell not
always kind of looked up to them as a an
ideal place to work on mobile games do
you think you're gonna stay here for a
long time
I bought a flat this week if that's real
put that on camera
other supercell imports like Bryce who
hails from France bring new characters
to life with their fancy pens they fight
among each other to get their characters
onto the most prized real estate the
games start up screen the loading screen
is that light that's the prize that's
the best parts of it for you of course
there's just one problem with putting
the creatives in charge
crazy-ass perfectionism the way this
philosophy is translated is that you
guys are very careful about what you
actually release and that you cancel
games all the time how many of you
killed over the last nine years
dozens or it's probably doesn't I think
there's some story that you're on a
plane and and in the time that you're
flying across some gamer you were pretty
happy about God got whacked yeah it was
actually one of my favorite games he'd
ever done I used to play it a lot for
example with my kid son and I really
really loved that game and then I just
heard what the team had got together I
guess in a typical Finnish Finnish sauna
and then they had had a like show of
hands but you know who believes that
this is the best game that they can make
you know I don't think that many like
hands went up and then they decided well
that's if that's okay let me show just
kill it
how did you explain that to your kids oh
you know I just I dunno that's me
I'm some doesn't call myself like the
least least powerful CEO my goal is that
themes make you know most difficult all
of all of the decisions which of course
means means that I make very little or
no decisions let's say that supercells
games are exactly good for you but I
will say that these fine people seem to
be having a good time making them and
bringing ungodly piles of cash to their
homeland in the process and you're
telling me you cannot get my son to
choice now go outside and play to see
what's next for the finished tech scene
i scooted right into a former hospital
which has been turned into a startup
incubator called Maria zero one this
place has it all
Gurney's more Gurney's tunnels full of
startup refuse wheelchairs hanging from
the ceiling and a cemetery right outside
where venture capital goes to die this
hospital is founded in night 1890s and
then we took over 2016 so currently we
serve over 130 startup companies
it's the largest startup canvas in the
Nordics the startups here make all types
of things from games to corporate
software but the freshest startup in
Moorea zero one is certainly enough
which produces a high-tech version of
the green wall until this is like
breathing in 1,000 trees at once
all around the world we see these plant
walls but this was the first one I've
ever that I've ever run into that had
yeah a lot of built-in technology into
it as well yeah so instead of a plant
being just a decorative part of that we
have removed altogether the soil from
the system almost all of the air
purification in plants happens in the
root zone microbes nothing the leaves as
people think okay and if the plant is
growing in soil the air is not touching
the microbes we could rid of the soil in
from the system and then on top of the
product there are fans so it biofilter
raise the air 24/7 in your home and this
makes the air purification of plants
efficiency over a hundred times more
more efficient and we're talking about
you sold like hundreds thousands yeah so
now it's the biggest Greenville company
in the world we have about three
thousand units in our customers place
right now
how can a bigger vision is how can we
help a billion people to enjoy nature
and breathe forests great area in the
built environment every day
now that we've learned that the shot
paddles have been applied in Finland's
tech scene has come back to life I would
like to show you just how much better
Finn's are as humans than the rest of us
next on hello world
sizzling fake meat planet friendly
straws that actually work in the Finnish
Walter White this is pretty legal okay